(gentle music)
- I've used creative communication
to solve problems related
to especially people
learning different science.
For example, in chemistry people
sometimes have a hard time
understanding subatomic particles
and molecules and atoms and
making those connections
between quantities and numbers.
So instead of jumping right into that
which can be very difficult for people,
I've learned to be
creative and use analogies
or relating that to something
that is more accessible
such as cooking or money
or building something.
And then when people can make the relation
between something large and familiar,
to something small or
subatomic and unfamiliar
it makes it easier for them
to make those connections
and build upon that knowledge.
So several years ago I started
making videos of myself
explaining biology and
entomology in language
that was accessible and
familiar to people my age
and people who don't fit
the stereotypical model
of a scientist.
It's a choice that I'm really
glad that I made actually.
I've received so much
positive feedback about videos
no more complicated than me
holding a bug in front of a camera.
And actually just like this,
me literally holding a
bug in front of a camera
and explaining what makes a tick.
Note to self,
I should make a video about
what makes ticks tick.
That'd be pretty cool.
Wait, sorry, that's
neither here nor there.
The point of what I'm saying is
the choice not to excise my personality,
the choice to bring all of my quirkiness
into how I communicate is what
seems to make the difference.
A big part of being creative
really can be just figuring out
how to bring all of you
to whatever it is that you choose to do.
(gentle music)